one of the issues that emerged late last
week the tom brady
instagram rants about the rule change
that expands dramatically the universe
of available jerseys i still don't know
why he waited until after yeah seriously
the rule was enacted
why do you wait why do you wait make it
known before wednesday do you not did
you not know everybody was talking about
it come on man
i i still i i don't get it
i i think it's overblown you're gonna
study film you're gonna know the numbers
of the guys that you're facing you know
that the linebacker wears seven you know
that the defensive back wears 33 you
know the outside linebacker wears two
you're gonna know all that i don't buy
this idea there's going to be chaos for
the offense because you got guys in
different jerseys well it's not going to
make it chaos but it's going to make it
harder it definitely is there's no doubt
about that you know again it's a game of
split second decisions things like that
and now
yes there is going to be a little bit of
that element and maybe not again mike
like you said like yeah you're gonna
know the starters and things like that
but it's gonna get into backups and
things like that to where now you're
gonna be like wait
wait is the backup
will linebacker number eight or is that
the free safety who's the backup safety
wait i'm not sure they kind of the same
body size it's gonna be those type of
things that's where it's gonna be
you know a little confusing and a game
of again where it's a blur and it's
snapshots you know
you're you're looking for little context
clues and for like a pass protecting
running back you know his rules usually
are secondary blitzers things like that
so he can look for those type of numbers
again it's not a game changer but it is
going to change things a little bit for
quarterbacks and centers and make life
harder on them
well misery does love company and the
coach who made tom brady miserable bill
belichick also agrees that's what got me
to stop and say oh wait a minute yeah
belichick hates this rule the patriots
one of a handful of teams that voted
against it only four or five were
against it it would take a nine to kill
it but the rule passes the numbers are
changing and we all got to get used to
it i like it i i think it was a long
time coming and if it was that big of a
deal strategically nick saban would be
utilizing it for to the full capacity at
alabama the game's more simple the
game's more simple in college so it just
it doesn't it doesn't matter quite as
much at the college level the nfl
the the past protections are
way more intricate and have way more
detailed rules and things like that to
where
sorting things out is a little bit more
important as compared to college
football where they just go hey all five
guys take a step to the right and
anybody to your right you block and then
we'll put the back to the left edge of
you and that's so there's a it's a
little different world that way but i
mean mike i'm not going to argue it too
hard you're you're right at the end of
the day these guys are making millions
of dollars they're smart they'll be okay
next topic knowing what you know now
would you rather have
chargers quarterback justin herbert or
bengals quarterback joe burrow for the
next five years justin justin herbert
that i'm i'm not even gonna pause with
that it's the verizon speed round and
i'm going speedy with that one because
one yeah we know joe burrow hurt his
knee so that's that that puts him behind
the eight ball in that conversation
alone and number two as awesome as joe
burrow looked before
you know hurting his knee
justin herbert looked awesomer so i
don't know what else to say
he looked awesomer i mean he was amazing
so i am going to go with justin herbert
and and let's remember joe burrow
started the season and i know there was
no offseason program there was no
preseason but he was the number one guy
from day one of training camp yeah
herbert was stuck behind tyrod taylor
up until the moment that taylor had his
unfortunate interaction with dr neal
and herbert got thrown into it he got
thrown into it yeah and he
never faltered never missed a beat
once there was enough film out there for
people to see what he did he paid kept
going he did and uh i i agree with you
and uh i i think i think as much as i
love joe burrow i'm rooting for him to
get over this knee injury and get back
to where he was justin herbert uh
and by virtue of the fact that he stayed
healthy if nothing else showed me a
little bit more last year and i know
that that's unavoidable but but when you
if you're gonna say next five years i'm
going to go with the safer bet and
justin herbert all right which alabama
receiver gets drafted first we talked
about this a little bit earlier is it
going to be devante smith or is it going
to be jail and water i'm going to go
with devonte smith i mean
it does sound like it's close there's no
doubt about it but i'm gonna go with
devante smith the heisman trophy winner
you know just everything he did last
year it's hard not to turn on the film
and just look at it and go whoa special
i'll go smith what do you bet you're
gonna go waddle i'm gonna go waddle
because i think the dolphins would take
waddle over smith and they're on unless
they trade down maybe they trade down
and somebody takes devante smith and
then waddle falls to them that's a way
that they could look at this and maybe
pull it off pointsbet has the over under
for both being gone by
11.5 for both and remember last year
people thought jerry judy was going to
go before henry rugs it was a little bit
of a surprise chris when rugs went to
the raiders before judy went to the
broncos yeah no i i know that was uh
that was a surprise so i i mean again
the fact that it's the second year in a
row we're talking about two alabama
receivers both going in the top 20 and
these two receivers really
i don't think it's even close as
compared to the two last year i like
judy and rugs there was a lot to like
but i don't think they're on the level
of these two these two to me are like
can't miss prospects gonna have great
careers there's no doubt about it in my
mind
which general manager has the most
stressful three days ahead of him in the
2021 draft man what are you i'm i'm this
one's like
this i go i know mine you want mine yeah
go ahead you go first howie rose i was
gonna say that too hop between the board
and caught between the amateur mel
keiper who owns the team right it's got
to be howie yeah right yeah i i how he
was who the hell is jeffrey lurie howie
was definitely one of the first names
that went into my went into my head just
because of course yeah the scrutiny
around the eagles the front office right
now
everything going on there you know after
that
i'm gonna go with the teams that have
picks i mean that you know let's say the
jets yeah the jets it's it's big time
you just traded away sam darnold you're
taking them you're taking zach wilson
you got another pick in the first round
you got a lot of picks in this draft
altogether they got a chance to like
make a splash and really turn their team
and help to turn the corner here so i'll
go with joe douglas as the uh the guy of
the next stressful three days
something you said they reminded me of
the low stress draft that the saints had
in 1999 because they traded all of their
drafts right to get ricky williams and
mike ditko went golfing on the second
day of the draft they had nothing to do
all their picks were gone it's amazing
all right
last question very importantly will you
believe anything you hear that is
attributed to
an anonymous scout at any point this
week no absolutely not and what i really
want to say too to a lot of this like
anonymous scout stuff i want to say is
like so what like the scouts don't know
anything nobody's telling them what's
going on in the organization yeah they
might know what players they like and
like what team what like the players
that are viewed as a high like high
level you know prospects for their team
but they don't know
the gm's the pro personnel guys the
owners they're not telling the scouts
either they don't know so
you know no i'm not going to believe any
of that
i never believe any of it whether it's
this week or any other weekend you know
i've had people push back to me
privately well the boards are set and
the teams know what they're going to do
and nothing these guys say is really
going to change anything no
the target i think is ownership
i believe that owners are far more
involved in the picks especially round
one than anyone will ever admit to us
and i think if you can make the owner
wobbly if you can get the owner to start
asking tough questions and we know how
much of a seaway cya exercise this whole
thing is yeah if the owner starts asking
questions about a guy that you have here
uh
you know in the you can tell the owners
the owners getting shaky that that it
can and look bottom line is
i know teams deliberately try to do it
they use the media to leak negative
information for guys they like so those
guys will slide i know for a fact that
it happens and when you know that it
happens what that means is no opinions
anonymously provided by any scouts
coaches or executives can ever be
trusted because the people who are
giving you those opinions have skin in
the game and we know that they do it
they try to do it they wouldn't waste
their time trying to do it chris if they
didn't think it potentially definitely
definitely and added to that like i'll
piggyback off of something you said
first off like not everybody board's set
right now no they're not they're still
tinkering with it right now you know all
the close calls and things like that we
we're hearing through reports the 49ers
they're five days away they've traded
for the number three pick they've just
got done with draft deliberations we
have multiple people saying that so that
just tells you they're not set in stone
anything right now i think there's a
number of teams where the important
decision makers really just got done
with all their homework as far as the
draft's concern in the last 10 days or
so so there is still tinkering with
these boards not everybody knows exactly
how this is going to play out so i think
there's still work to be done here and
now i'm not i'm with you i'm not
believing anything from anybody's mouth
right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports